can we start the presentation yeah so
we've prepared a presentation on what
the next Borderlands game will be you're
looking at an engine rendered image from
the very beginning of Borderlands 3 look
at the environment its Pandora the art
the style the goal was to try to create
an image that was fresh but also
familiar we wanted to look forward and
taking full advantage of today's
technology in a way that respects that
one-of-a-kind art direction known
throughout the video game world that's
the borderlands art style okay let's be
honest this isn't an actual screenshot
from the game what you're looking at is
the game
now we've skipped past the logos and a
lot of the introductions because we felt
that the most honest way to bring the
game to you today was to start from the
very beginning so with that let's play
some Borderlands 3 ima cl4 PTP Stewart
but but you can just call me general
claptrap about crimson raiders amara
thanks i'll preorder your 2 stones just
in cakes now those jerks are trying to
murder you are the children of the fault
of bandit cult and follow their creepy
leaders with blind devotion which
reminds me if you're going to obey my
every fetid call you don't need an echo
device try it out I rinsed it off myself
the echo 3 slightly more powerful than
co2 and twice as expensive now listen up
recruit Lilith ordered us to take over a
children of the bulk propaganda center
time to show those filthy weirdos that
no one messes with the crimson raiders
follow me recruit
so Lilith's
ordered us to take over the recruitment
center of the children of the vault in
the introduction that we skipped you
would learn that the children of the
vault is a new cult that's emerged on
Pandora
siren Lilith and the Crimson Raiders are
recruiting new vault hunters that's you
that's us and we are to investigate that
children of the vault cult and discover
who their mysterious leaders are
before we recon righteous vengeance
you'll need to register your echo at
this weight change once we defeat the
cult I'll be famous and when I signing
autographs I need you looking sharp
while defending me from my legions of
fans slash daughters alright now as you
can see here we're playing as Amara and
she's a powerful siren warrior and like
claptrap mentioned we're in the quick
change where it's up to you how you want
your character to look so you can change
Amara and changer emotes obviously
alright so obviously you're giving a
glimpse here on how we use the beginning
of the game to make sure players are up
to speed on how first-person video games
work we can validate that players
understand how to navigate the
environment and interact with it
we'll even be able to know that a
player's learned how to crouch and how
to slide got to make sure you can jump
and if you miss that you can mantle up
you climb the higher ledges so as with
most games where we get using the
beginning to make sure that we teach the
fundamentals we're also setting the tone
of the game right
just like our unique art style we want
people to feel right away what we
believe helps to make Borderlands
special a style of writing that's both
irreverent and genuine
[Applause]
so out the window alright so as claptrap
just mentioned in order to stay
competitive some of our gun
manufacturers have added alternate
firing modes and if we look here we can
see that we have a blatte off pistol and
if we just fire regularly we just fire
bullets but if we switch our alternate
firing modes we fire off micro missiles
now later in the game you'll find guns
that can switch between ice bullets and
fire bullets or you might find guns that
have a chain gun on top but when you
switch firing modes it'll shoot out
grenades it gets pretty crazy and then
players who maximize all firing modes
will have like twice the guns available
then they had to start with
[Music]
[Music]
and super general about pricks and
writers we have you completely
surrounded
open the gates now themselves killed
another fault but there's still another
victory for the Crimson Raiders
[Music]
see the degrading cover
oh for the last three phrases M for
Mature
I know claptrap can be a little [ __ ] but
he's still one of us
you're gonna have to say I'll be there
soon so let's let's see if we can find
some loot I saw over near that door I
saw a red chest it looks like a trunk of
a car
[Music]
what do we got here what else is that oh
that's interesting
alright so we can see that this weapon
has high accuracy higher handling let's
look at the other one all right and this
weapon has higher damage in a higher
reload time so I decided Furness or
brute force in this case so what do you
guys think should we shoot from the hip
or should we go with that badass go okay
I think I think you guys said scope but
I heard say you know what take both of
them we'll try this go pinellas which
that's pretty badass these are like
level 1 guns too
Oh
[Applause]
or else flammable
okay we need a shield this is an area
mission so if we look around we should
be able to find some somewhere stack
pile Daquan you on this all right that
looks promising there we go 77 105
that's better take that one so I know
you guys are getting ahead of me you can
know it's coming next this is uh this is
our first mini boss fight decline you
ready we're flying without a net here no
God mode so
[Music]
Oh God
[Applause]
you trap security air escapes dynamic so
it's like different every time they play
it I was like the best kill ever I'm
glad you guys got to see that now you'll
notice that Daquan picked up the shotgun
that ship dropped we think it's really
important that your moment of victory
should be have a subsequent rate war to
it right at that moment so of course you
can pick up gear right away all right
dude Daquan has the same affliction I
have where you have to open every single
freaking chest this is a demo we can
just yeah it's so tempting those green
lights Oh claptrap snagging at us
already so it's not a borderlands game
of course unless claptrap jumps between
being needy and bossy and just pathetic
I don't know how you guys feel about
them but I still kind of love claptrap
so let's help them out in Borderlands 3
you can revive NPCs and NPCs can revive
you let's help out claptrap
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well the cults destroyed every other
Crimson Raiders stronghold so this will
have to do for now
what's your name killer I am Amara nice
tattoos siren sista you must be the
voice in my head
yeah about that not the weirdest thing
you're gonna see on Pandora but
seriously thanks for answering my call
we might not have the numbers but with a
badass like you we've got a fighting
chance
welcome to the crimson ringers hey you
you're bloodthirsty screaming you're CLV
let's see what you got recruit
she's pretty rap